good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight say what you will about
elected Democrats but they know where
the power is they're like truffle pigs
for power no matter how thick the forest
is they will find it here's one example
in his very first hours in office
literally on inauguration day Joe Biden
named a new head of the Criminal
Division at the justice department now
Biden spent that same day you will
remember lecturing the rest of us about
Equity meaning that straight white men
are bad
and yet strangely the person he chose
for this job was not a member of a
racial or sexual minority he was instead
a highly privileged straight white guy
he was called Nick McQuaid Nick McQuade
went to private schools he rode at
Wesleyan he went to Columbia for law
school he was definitely not oppressed
but that did not matter to Joe Biden
some jobs are too important for
affirmative action
mcquaid's main qualification was being
the former law partner of Hunter Biden's
criminal attorney
in December of 2020 Hunter Biden hired a
Latham and Watkins lawyer called Chris
Clark to defend him against potential
federal tax charges just a month later
Hunter Biden's dad hired Chris Clark's
partner Nick McQuade to oversee the
agency that could bring those federal
tax charges
that seems like an obvious and glaring
conflict but no Nick McQuaid did not
recuse himself from the hunter Biden
investigation and so more than two years
later not surprisingly no charges have
been brought against Hunter Biden and
it's not for lack of evidence
for years now the FBI has had possession
of Hunter Biden's laptop on that laptop
as you know is a detailed account of how
the Biden family made millions of
dollars from foreign governments selling
access to the U.S government through Joe
Biden
so the question is among many did Hunter
Biden pay federal taxes on all of that
dough
what do you think
this is a guy who left a crack pipe and
his driver's license in a rental car
because he was too high to put them back
into his pocket did he pale his federal
taxes
let's just say 100 by does not fit the
profile of a faithful taxpayer
but he is the president's son
and that's why when he was asked about
the criminal investigation into his
taxes two years ago he didn't seem that
worried watch
at the end of last year Biden
acknowledged an ongoing investigation by
federal authorities for potential tax
law violations is your legal team
working on any kind of a plea deal oh no
I am absolutely certain that what we're
doing is is being completely Cooperative
with whoever is asking from a from any
Authority whatsoever the implication all
through the campaign was that your
efforts had somehow benefited your
father financially have you ever given
your father money from any of your
business ventures no nothing nothing
ever not a nickel not a nickel directly
or indirectly directly or indirectly not
a nickel ever 100 percent no never
oh you lie you lie that was two years
ago weirdly we haven't heard a lot about
the federal tax investigation into
Hunter Biden since
and it is strange if you think about it
since we now have tens of thousands of
new IRS agents to enforce tax law
and in fact it wasn't that long ago that
the Biden justice department do you
remember this
indicted Donald Trump's 75 year old
accountant because he failed to declare
the full value of his work vehicle
I think he was in handcuffs but somehow
these same enforcers of the law cannot
be bothered to bring the hunter Biden
investigation to fruition not when they
have a laptop proving that he took
Millions from the government of China
how does that work exactly did he pay
every dollar in federal taxes did he
fully declare the value of his work
vehicle or of his crack
what about the Russian hookers
by the way at the same time doj doesn't
seem interested at all in the fact that
Hunter Biden lied on a federal gun form
go ahead and try that yourself at home
it's a felony you'll go to jail
but hunter Biden is not in jail he's
making art in his garden in LA
is what we're seeing what it looks like
well we can finally answer that question
thanks to a career special agent at the
IRS who's decided to blow the whistle on
the corruption in the Biden
Administration
this whistleblower it's just informed
Congress that he has proof that the
Attorney General of the United States
mayor Garland lied under oath about the
hunter Biden investigation that's a
felony
so the Attorney General of the United
States committed a felony according to
this whistleblower who also says he has
seen quote preferential treatment and
politics and properly infecting
decisions and protocols throughout the
agency
and that these
changes in standard protocol were
designed to quote benefit the
politically connected
so what we've learned here is exactly
you suspected all along the Biden people
are criminals watch
my client wants to come forward to
Congress he's ready to be questioned
about what he knows and what he
experienced under the proper legal
protections attorney Mark ladle's client
is a supervisory special agent at the
IRS who's prepared to tell Congress the
investigation he's been working on has
been hampered by what he thinks his
special treatment typical steps that a
law enforcement investigator would take
were compromised because of political
considerations CBS News has learned the
investigation The Whistleblower worked
on is about Hunter Biden Lytle told us
the Whistleblower has been with the IRS
for more than a decade and has extensive
documentation to support his allegations
the things he's been through are are
very well documented in emails and other
Communications with the Department of
Justice
including proof that our sleazeball
attorney general whose presence in that
job is an offense against the law and
tradition of this country wide under
oath of felonies this is not a small
story Kareem Jean-Pierre was asked about
all of this day at the White House why
is the Department of Justice sending
working-class grandmothers to prison for
walking around the capitol the people's
house
well they bury criminal investigations
into the president's son
here was her non-response
president has
owed during the campaign during his
presidency that the Department of
Justice should have Independence they
should not be politicized and they
should be able to do their job
independently essentially and so I'll
leave it to them I'll leave it to
Department of Justice to make their
decision to do to uh to move forward
with this particular case
her presence is designed to insult the
country and it's working but it won't
last forever because this is a real
story Miranda Devine as always is on it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight